a couple of you guys have recently been
asking what the best way to select an
architecture school is
well it's a very difficult question but
today we're going to tackle it head on
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is dave
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about
architecture and technology my
background is obviously in architecture
i'm a redstone architect in the state of
western australia
but i'm also a technology lover and an
entrepreneur so if any of those things
interest you make sure you smash that
subscribe button
because today we're talking about
architecture and selecting the perfect
architectural university
there's going to be a lot of different
points in this video so i'm going to try
and make this interesting and creative
by running around this house like a
madman and taking as many shots as i can
architecture can be a pretty demanding
and time consuming course
so the first thing you want to look at
is how long the course
actually is most courses here in
australia are three years
plus two years for your masters plus
another two years in the actual real
world
so if you're looking for a good course
make sure it's about that five year mark
make sure that the course you do select
has pretty good fees and fee
options the last thing you want to be
doing is opening up your fridge and
having absolutely no food in it
whatsoever
when we talk about fees there's only
really two different structures you
should really focus on
one do they offer student loans or two
do they not
some universities give you a student
loan that is at a pretty good rate
for as long as you need so once you
start earning a decent amount of money
you can actually start paying this loan
off other universities don't have this
option which means you have to come up
with the money
straight away before you even start
studying so
for example one university might be ten
thousand dollars a year the other might
be four
there's probably a pretty good reason
for the difference in price but at the
end of the day
you can only go to what you can afford
now another thing you have to consider
is that course online or is it at a
campus
does this matter to you do you want to
be studying from home 24 7 or
do you want to have that experience and
go to a campus
right now i don't know if there's too
much of a difference between courses
if you pick a really good online
university versus a really good campus
university
but it is a personal choice so it's
something you have to consider
personally i think campus is the way to
go because
you get a lot more one-on-one time with
your tutors you really do need
to sit down draw and walk through some
plans
with your tutors if you're going to
study architecture studying online is
all well and good and technology is
definitely caught up to make this
possible
but i still think campus is a much
better option the next thing you have to
consider is how demanding is this course
how many hours do you have to spend at
university or online
is this going to leave you with enough
time to work part-time job
do you need a work part-time job if so
do you even have to step back down and
only do your course part-time
this is just something that you have to
think about before you even begin
thinking about individual universities
or colleges
okay so we've got through the boring
stuff before you even select the
university
now let's say you've narrowed it down to
a few universities in your area
or the ones that you really want to go
to the first thing you want to focus on
is the actual course curriculum do they
have any electives in the first couple
of years
what are those electives those electives
are the ones that are going to
differentiate you from all the other
students in that course
so make sure that you pick an elective
that has some sort of relevance to the
architecture industry
in my personal experience i picked a
graphic design course it taught me
photoshop
indesign illustrator all of those things
and it was fantastic
it was something that i still use to
this day in my professional career other
electives on course are things like
interior design courses
construction management or anything with
technical drawing
you really want to get good at these
elements because you're going to get
tested on them especially construction
management and project management
later on down the track when you go to
register to become an architect
when you're looking through that course
list you want to make sure it's filled
with practical and technical work
and less theory work that's just my
opinion
based on my experience practical work is
things where you actually go out and
design
architecture you design houses you
design commercial properties
and technical work is where you get to
the nitty-gritty details you understand
the formation the construction process
and everything that goes into building a
house the theory is obviously the
history of architecture
and all sorts of different theoretical
architectural principles
this is all well and good and you
definitely have to learn something to
get your head around architecture
but i do believe that your time is
better spent on the practical and the
technical
now you've worked through the curriculum
and you know exactly what you're getting
taught
but who are you getting taught by the
ratio of teachers to students isn't that
important
unless it's one to one hundred for
example if it's one to ten
one to twenty that's pretty normal and
that's okay i personally believe it's
more important that you understand
who's teaching you and who the lecturers
are so for example are the lecturers
only lecturers and have they only
lectured their whole life
or are they actual practicing architects
as well as lecturers
the guys and girls that are practicing
architects as well as lecturers are the
ones that you genuinely want to learn
from
now don't get me wrong here the ones
that have been lecturing for a very long
time are exceptional as well
but i'm thinking more long term here
unless you want to end up as a
researcher in the architecture field
then disregard this advice but if you
want to work as a practicing architect
then make sure you befriend those
architects that are lecturers as well
they're the ones that are most likely
going to give you a job after you've
finished your master's degree
or even potentially during if you're a
high enough achiever so as you walk into
university make sure you have a plan
make sure you know what kind of
architecture you want to do do you want
to be a residential a commercial
architect do you want to work for a big
firm or a small firm
plan this out because you're going to
have to take advantage of that from day
one
you're going to find those lecturers
that are architects and our lecturers at
the same time
hang on to them learn from them and
master as much as you can
because they are more valuable than the
entire course itself
and finally you want to think about the
facilities in the campus does the campus
have 3d printers does it have laser
cutters
cnc machines plotters a1 printers a3
printers
does it have any of this on site and on
campus what about a workshop if you want
to create a model or anything of that
sort if you are studying on campus
these things are usually somewhere the
campuses are usually pretty large
and it takes a little bit of hunting but
make sure you know if they have this at
your university of choice
now a couple of the less important
things in my personal opinion at least
one parking and travel a lot of
universities are cutting down on the
parking and
limitations to traveling to the
university they're encouraging public
transport and riding your bike and all
sorts of sustainable practices
which is great if you're studying
architecture because it all ties in but
if you live pretty far away then you
want to be able to drive and make sure
you can get there on time especially if
you have to go to a part-time
job after so that's just something you
have to take into consideration
if you are going to drive to campus
you're probably going to spend a long
time there as an architect or an
architecture student
i know i spend 48 50 hours there in any
given time without any sleep so campus
amenities are pretty important
does that campus have a nice pub or a
bistro or something you can go to
during your lunch break with your mates
just to hang out and discuss
and just create those real friendships
that are going to last forever
because university is just as important
for learning and knowledge as it is for
creating lifelong friendships you can't
forget about the sporting facilities as
well
does it have a gym does it have a pool
does it have all sorts of things like
this
because again most likely you're going
to be spending most of your time on
campus
so if you can condense your whole life
to that campus it is the most ideal
situation
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for joining me i hope
you enjoyed this video and i hope you
enjoyed the little quirky house tour at
the same time
if there's anything else you'd like to
know make sure you leave a comment down
below i'm happy to answer
any questions you have whatsoever
because this video forms one of my 28
videos in 28 days for february of 2021
it would usually be i'll see you next
monday but in this case
i'll see you tomorrow